- So before I get into that,
let's talk a little bit
about what the fuck is machine learning?
'cause it's something that
I think a lot of people
don't really understand.
I'm sure in this crew,
almost all of you
understand it in some way
but you have to take the remarks
that I've prepared here to tonight
and so I'm just gonna go
ahead and walk through this.
The way I have been
explaining it to people
and I'll be curious tonight
to have anybody here sort
of help me refine this.
I'm trying to get better at it.
Is you have a big amount of messy data.
You don't know what to do with it,
you don't wanna pay
people to go through it,
you don't wanna sit yourself
and go through it.
So instead, you find comparable data,
training data that in some way
has either direct application
to the data you're looking at,
it's like a tiny subset of it
or it's close enough of a parallel
that it might be useful in some way.
You use that to then
create basically examples
of right and wrong answers
that you can give to an algorithm
and then using those
right and wrong examples,
instead of just straight
coding instructions,
you can then turn that algorithm loose
to apply the rules it has learned
on the messy data that you started with.
So here's an example
of how that might work.
Let's say you wanna ask an algorithm,
okay, algorithm, tell me which is which.
Which is a cow and which is a dog?
Tell me the difference
between these two things
in a bunch of photographs
I'm about to give you?
Or in some other piece,
some data that's full of cows and dogs.
Tell me the difference
between these two things.
If you give the system enough cows
and tell it, these are
correct pictures of cows
and you give it enough pictures of dogs
and say these are actually dogs,
you can, in fact, teach it enough examples
that it can draw the
distinction between the two.
The AI uses patterns to label the data.
That's really all it comes down to.
So when you think about it
in terms of just a system
that just is trying to draw a distinction
between categories, you
really begin to understand
that it doesn't actually know anything
beyond the basic, barest minimum it needs
to distinguish between those two things.
So let's say that in a
bunch of data you've got
on cows and dogs, there are
two variables you can look at.
Their size and their slobber,
right? (audience chuckling)
It picks those out.
Says here's one that's really consistent
in the examples you've given me,
and out of that, it can begin charting,
oh the dogs fall into the slobber category
and they're a little smaller in size.
Here's the cows, they're bigger.
They slobber some but not too much.
And out of that, you can draw this line
that distinguishes between the two.
This one is dogs, sorry, this one is cows,
this side dogs.
You're just teaching it how to
distinguish between the two.
People think that, I think
sort of the misperception
among the many, many
people that I talk to tends
to be that there's something
more sophisticated going on
in this but really, it is just
describing the difference.
Machine learning really
just uses the patterns
to just draw that distinguishing line.
That's really all it comes down to.
So I think for me what's
so important to understand
is that it doesn't really know anything
about dogs or cows, it just
knows the simplest possible way
to tell the difference based
on the data you've given it.
(bell ringing)